[Music]
the predator franchise was broken so how
can one movie turn everything around
prey found a way
2018 the predator felt like the final
fatal hit to a franchise that had been
bleeding out for years now dan
tragdenberg the director of 10
cloverfield lane has picked up the scent
of the iconic alien hunter and is going
back a few hundred years with prey the
new film sees comanche warrior naru
played by amber mid thunder square off
with everyone's favorite space invader
to protect her home and obtain honor
within her tribe thankfully early
reactions and critical responses confirm
that prey isn't just a great watch but
the best entry in the franchise since
the first one
i've been practicing
it's time i'm ready
avoiding the traps that so many big
prequels have been caught in over the
years praise sends us down a very
different trail than the previous films
and it's all the better for it
in 1987 john mctnn's predator did
something no other action movie had
prior it made you genuinely scared for
the safety of arnold schwarzenegger the
austrian oak who had made a career out
of being indestructible became anything
but fighting to survive as a lone
soldier dutch in an almost dialogue free
finale that had the role of hunter and
hunted changing on a dime the thrill of
the chase between a lone human and a
technologically advanced beast was a
highlight but it was a plot beat that
became stale and the franchise entries
that followed where the underrated
predators aside too much time was spent
on each film's trophies to be trying to
figure out what they were getting
tracked by trachtenberg's blood-soaked
session avoids that mistake instead
giving the dreadlocked death dealer a
worthy opponent in the form of naru who
quickly concludes that something else
besides her tribe is out hunting
i'm not frightened by a bear
i don't think it was a bear this lets
the film cut to the chase that fans are
keen to see between the two lone hunters
just like before it's a clear indicator
that time is unquestionably on
trachtenberg's side including when it
comes to the film setting which resets
the history of the predator in all the
best ways
as much as we tried to forget it a
flimsy flashback in alien vs predator
showed the titular trophy seekers
building pyramids the issue is that they
are as tooled up then as they are when
they encountered dutch in the 1987 film
raising the question of whether or not
their russian safari trips were really a
challenge thankfully prey retcons that
smudge in the history books for a less
developed predator which in turn gives
prey an unexpected upgrade the space
hunter with naru in his sights is a
clear ancestor of the ones we're used to
mandibles and all brandishing headgear
that looks to be made from the skins of
his former kills rather than that
unmistakable face place establishes a
technological timeline for the alien
race doing so tightens a gap between
both sides still certifying the predator
as a threat but one more likely to bleed
thanks to its low-tech arsenal
trachtenberg told collider it was very
tricky to find a way to have the
predator feel at once 300 years earlier
in iteration and in what it has to wield
but also feel far more advanced on what
our characters are used to and i've ever
dealt with before
it's an exciting take on the creature
that also suggests the future of the
franchise might be in the past
prey has revived the franchise to its
former glory by putting the legendary
bone collector in an era we've never
seen it in before it's a game-changing
choice that also opens up other
historical possibilities for the
predator prey chronicles the oldest
known hunt of the franchise's violent
visitors but it doesn't mean it was the
first how might the iconic aliens have
handled samurai warriors did this race
that thrives in the heat of battle ever
go up against vikings if not why not
should such an approach be taken it
would be great to see any follow-up film
have the same attention to detail as
prey one that could focus on a culture
that until now has been given skewed or
little representation in mainstream
media setting up an all the more
compelling story because of it
prey gives us a new take on an old foe
by dropping a predator into a story
populated predominantly by native
american stars including its lead their
creative choice spawned from the image
of sunny lanterns billy dutch's native
american scout and his last stand in the
1987 film 35 years later it still
resonated with dan trachtenberg who told
empire in prey we're watching someone
lead this movie that has never led this
type of movie before to ensure such a
crucial part of the film was carefully
handled comanche and blackfeet american
indian producer jane myers joins the
project operating as a film's cultural
advisor her input changed the potential
franchise money spinner into one of the
most intriguing installments to the
predator franchise to date in a rare
move in hollywood akamashi language cut
off the film will also be available to
stream upon release
whenever these spine snatching stalkers
have visited earth on screen women have
often been the least of their worries
with el padilla carillo's anna from the
original film not being deemed a threat
and maria conchisha alonso's the owner
getting passed over for the sake of her
unborn baby in predator 2 it was left to
the tough men of hollywood to put the
yautja in check prey finally breaks
those dated hunting traditions in the
best ways possible thanks to not only
one of the best performances in the
franchise but also one that fleshes out
a character at the core of a story worth
investing in
why do you want to hunt
because you all think that i can't
whereas the previous films were about
fighting for survival against an
invisible threat prey focuses on a hero
determined to prove herself even before
the iconic tri-laser gets fired up naru
wants to be respected in her tribe so
much so that she's willing to go up
against a grizzly bear-disposing monster
from the skies to get her the safety of
her people is an understandable concern
but seeing her fight for her self-worth
is an added element that puts prey on a
different playing field than the other
predator films and it's thanks to amber
mid thunder that it all works so well